not Manhunt taking the work of several
law enforcement agencies including the
U.S Marshal Service the FBI and Metro
Police 8 news now investigator Vanessa
Murphy just outside of Metro Police
Headquarters with what those agencies
are saying
the concern is the escaped inmate had a
four-day Head Start before police tried
catching him now the focus is how he was
able to escape in the first place and
how no one inside Nevada prisons noticed
he was missing for four days this is
Porfirio Duarte Herrera being taken into
custody last night in downtown Las Vegas
Sheriff Joe Lombardo pointing out how
dangerous the convicted killer is and
acknowledging with a case of an escaped
inmate like him this could have ended a
lot worse as we've reported sources say
the prisoner used a cardboard dummy in
his cell used acid to corrode metal to
escape out of his window and climbed
over a barbed wire fence the last time
he was accounted for in the prison was
Friday evening the Department of
Correction saying staff noticed he was
missing Tuesday Morning the question how
could this happen are you 100 confident
that the prison only realized he was
missing seeing Tuesday morning or do you
believe anyone had knowledge he was
missing on Friday Saturday sooner than
that I don't want to guess to anything
Vanessa I I don't have confidence in any
of those questions that you just
presented we've reached out to the
Department of Corrections multiple times
for answers and have not received a
response Governor Steve cislak is
calling for an investigation Sheriff Joe
Lombardo says he is confident the
prison's Inspector General will do a
thorough investigation now important to
note here Sheriff Joe Lombardo and
Governor Steve sisilak are running
against each other in the governor's
race Sheriff Lombardo saying as this
search was taking place no one was
playing the blame game but that question
remains how could this have happened
reporting at Metro Police Headquarters
Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now